[Musique]
[Rires]
bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de mode d'emploi un numéro spécial
consacré aux filières qui recrutent à
saint quentin en yvelines
sans plus tarder voici le sommaire
immersion dans l'entreprise sem espaces
verts à plaisir depuis plus de 40 ans la
société embellie les espaces verts de
l'agglomération un secteur dynamique et
offre de nombreuses opportunités des
opportunités l'on en a aussi chez
kangourou kids cette franchise installé
sur notre territoire est spécialisée
dans la garde d'enfants à domicile et
les sorties d'école et puis en plateau
nous parlerons également d'autres
filières dynamique à saint quentin en
yvelines avec nos invités
céline l'insolent la directrice
recrutement un système technologies et
stéphanie richard senior manager pour le
cabinet de recrutement
walter spipoll mais tout d'abord
quelques chiffres pour ouvrir ce
magazine deuxième pôle économique de
l'ouest parisien saint quentin en
yvelines recentre sur son territoire
seize mille entreprises 35 grands
groupes mais aussi des pme et des tpe
l'agglomération compte 142 mille emplois
occupés par 41% des saint quentinois des
emplois qui sont répartis dans plusieurs
secteurs l'administration l'automobile
l'aéronautique l'industrie la
construction ou encore des services
divers mais pour ce premier reportage je
vous propose de vous mettre au vert
il faut savoir que 60 1 % du territoire
de l'agglomération est occupé par des
espaces verts et des plans d'eau et des
espaces qu'il faut bien sûr entretenir
c'est le rôle des entreprises de paysage
à l'image de sem espaces verts reportage
entretenir les jardins des collectivités
et la guerre ou bien encore taillé
depuis 40 ans l'entreprise sem espace
vert basé à plaisir intervient en région
parisienne ainsi que dans le nord de la
france une société où l'on retrouve
plusieurs types de métiers qui ont tous
des points communs pour travailler dans
les jardins il faut aimer la nature il
faut être rigoureux vous êtes autonome
faut aimer les plantes faut pas avoir
peur de travailler parce que bon
c'est qu'elle que c'est un métier qui
parfois est physique mais qui donne
entièrement satisfaction
bosseur et jardins la nature on est au
soleil régulièrement bien sûr parfois il
pleut mais il fait quand même plus
souvent soleil que de pluie une filière
dynamique à saint quentin en yvelines
une filière qui ne connaît pas la crise
c'est un secteur constamment en
évolution
on parle beaucoup de développement
durable il ya beaucoup d'énergie pour ce
genre de métier effectivement c'est tout
à fait porter et d'ailleurs nous
embauchons nous embauchons régulièrement
parmi les 60 salariés que compte
l'entreprise jérémy robert il s'occupe
notamment de l'entretien d'un jardin
municipal à montigny le bretonneux
il fait ce métier depuis une quinzaine
d'années j'ai fait deux ans de saper
deux ans de bep et ensuite je suis
rentré dans le monde du travail à à 21
ans et après bon bah je suis passé dans
différentes sociétés je suis passé deux
heures dans le public dans le privé ce
pour savoir de quoi on parle
c'est bien d'avoir un vécu ce qui me
plaît dans ce métier c'est que ces
diverses et variées c'est que le
résultat du travail
et est visible beaucoup plus que dans
certains métiers
c'est tout de suite le rendu en fin de
journée et la haie
et ça fait plaisir à voir c'est
valorisant particularité dans ce secteur
il n'est pas nécessaire d'avoir un
diplôme une expérience professionnelle
peut suffire
sem espaces verts proposent une
formation interne pour accéder aux
différents métiers
il faut tout simplement être motivé
changement de secteur à présent puisque
nous allons parler d'ingénierie avec
notre premier invité
bonjour céline blin ceux-là bonjour
alors vous êtes directrice recrutement a
system technology à saint quentin en
yvelines
présentez-nous votre votre entreprise
alors un système technologie aujourd'hui
c'est une entreprise d'ingénierie
industrielle qui compte 9000
collaborateurs dans le monde et qui
emploie des ingénieurs et des
techniciens chez nos grands donneurs
d'ordre industriels tels que renault
alstom airbus alors et c'est à saint
quentin en yvelines il ya combien de
salariés ici à 50 ans in fine on a
environ 1000 collaborateurs répartis à
la fois sur le site de
montigny-le-bretonneux et chez les
clients directement par exemple le
centre technocentre à guyancourt chez
renault
quels sont les métiers représentés les
métiers représentés sont très très vaste
aujourd'hui sur l'agglomération sur le
département des yvelines
on a aussi bien des métiers
de l'automobile que des métiers du
ferroviaire ou de l'aéro l'aéronautique
est aussi bien des métiers techniciens
que des métiers ingénieurs en
particulier notre notre coeur de cible
en ce moment c'est le les jeunes
diplômés puisque on est en plein dans la
saison des jeunes diplômés des sorties
d'école qui représente aujourd'hui 30 %
de recrutement au sein d'un système
alors on parlera recrutement dans
quelques instants mais en quoi ces
métiers que vous venez nous citer sont
porteurs aussi à 50 ans aujourd'hui
l'ingénierie est un secteur porteur en
tant que tel puisque les grands donneurs
d'ordres effectivement veulent
bénéficier du savoir faire technique
d'assystem sur la conception de la
recherche et développement
du manufacturing et ce qui permet
effectivement de proposer des projets
d'envergure et des projets porteurs
d'innovation à nous à nos futurs
recrutés alors il ya un mois système
lancé une grande opération de
recrutement à saint quentin en yvelines
il y avait 150 postes de disponibles est
ce que c'est toujours le cas tout à fait
même plus que ça puisque ça ne
concernait qu'une partie des locaux une
partie de l'activité
aujourd'hui on a plus de 300 postes à
pourvoir sur sur le bassin d'emploi
autant dans le secteur automobile que
dans le secteur aéronautique qui a
généré cette opération job dating
il faut d'expérience j'imagine pour ces
profils recherchés sont pas
obligatoirement tous profils et admis du
jeune diplômé jusqu'à aux profils
seniors et bien sûr pour celles et ceux
qui nous regardent et qui sont
intéressés par ces postes on peut aller
directement sur votre site internet 1
tout à fait assystem recrute.com c'est
la porte d'entrée pour nos offres
d'emploi
merci céline la salade est revenue sur
le plateau de mode d'emploi amercian
zone à présent sur un autre secteur qui
ne connaît pas la crise en france et
notamment sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines la garde d'enfants
lorsque l'on est parent et que l'on
travaille bien il est souvent difficile
voire même impossible d'aller récupérer
ses enfants à la sortie d'école et bien
c'est là qu'interviennent les agences
spécialisée dans la garde d'enfants à
l'image de kangourou kids qui recrute
d'ailleurs des new look tout au long de
l'année
reportage est-ce que vous avez pris
votre cv s'il vous plaît c'est être
candidate fera peut-être bientôt partie
des 85 nounou employés par l' agence
kangourou kids de saint quentin en
yvelines
ce réseau présent partout en france est
spécialisée dans la garde d'enfants à
domicile et les sorties d'école ou notre
job c'est de faire une pré sélection de
candidates en fonction d'un cahier des
charges bien spécifiques
et de proposer une candidate une
première candidate ou un premier
candidat à la famille qui le valide et
après on s'occupe de toute la partie
administrative avant eliane était
infirmière mais depuis plus d'un an elle
a été recrutée par kangourou kids pour
s'occuper de camille est thomas après
l'école durant les mois où il n'y a pas
de vacances scolaires elle touche
environ 440 euros nets en travaillant
quatre jours par semaine entre 16h et
18h30
bon ce qu'il faut c'est d'être à
l'écouté être dynamique
à voir sans responsabilités quand même
c'est une grosse responsabilité on nous
confie les parents nous confient leur
maison falleur enfants en priorité
après les clés de la maison etc il va
goûter et après on joue en attendant de
papa et maman arrive aimez le contact
avec les enfants avoir de la patience et
avoir de l'expérience dans la garde
d'enfants voilà quelques critères
recherchés par kangourou kids qui voit
les demandes des parents augmenté chaque
année une des seules filières a continué
je dirais à créer beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'emplois
pour la simple et bonne raison qu'on a
de toute façon toujours besoin de deux
nounous
il faut faire le lien entre 18 heures le
temps de rentrer au domicile les
structures telles que les crèches les
haltes garderies les écoles ferment
leurs portes à ses taux il faut pouvoir
faire ce lien dans les offres d'emploi
sont nombreuses toute l'année ce qui
permet à ce secteur de tirer son épingle
du jeu après le secteur des espaces
verts de l'ingénierie et de la garde
d'enfants et bien je vous propose de
parler recrutement d'experts avec notre
deuxième invité si bon jour stéphanie
richard vous êtes senior manager chez
walter spipoll à saint quentin en
yvelines alors wolters people c'est un
cabinet de recrutement européen est ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire plus voilà
nous sommes un cabinet de recrutement
spécialisé sur les métiers tertiaires
tous les métiers supports
on a effectivement notre siège sur paris
porte maillot et on a un bureau ici à
montigny sur pour retravailler sur toute
la zone effectivement de saint quentin
depuis quand justement votre argent sans
votre agence est implantée à 58 ans on a
la chance d'avoir un bassin très riche
donc ça a été la décision d'autres
directions de s'installer au coeur de
l'activité de 50 e alors il s'agit de
recrutement permanent mais aussi des de
recrutement intérimaire
qu'est ce qui vous distingue d'une
entreprise intérimaire classique alors
effectivement on est déjà spécialisé sur
les métiers tertiaires donc métiers
notamment comptables finances ressources
humaines tous les métiers business
support assistanat secrétariat et autres
effectivement par rapport à d'autres
structures
on aura on n'est pas sur la rue on est
en en étage et on opère avec des
entretiens individuels avec les
candidats que nous rencontrons vous
proposer des postes dans une dizaine de
deux secteurs est ce que un petit peu
nous nous en dire plus
voilà alors on travaille avec différents
secteurs d'activité l'industrie
automobile l'industrie pharmaceutique la
restauration tout ce qui concerne
également le commerce et la distribution
et différentes tailles d'entreprises
puisqu'on a la chance d'avoir beaucoup
de sièges sociaux sur le bassin d'emploi
mais également des pme des tpe on peut
travailler avec tous les secteurs et
toutes étaient bien d'entreprises font
appel à vous alors on travaille environ
avec 200 entreprises
avec aujourd'hui on va dire entre 80 et
100 postes ouverts imagine qu'il ya des
offres en ce moment beaucoup exempt cité
pas tout évidemment
alors il travaille beaucoup sur les
métiers notamment dans tout ce qui
concerne administration des ventes
l'assistanat commercial les postes en
comptabilité finance comptable
fournisseurs comptable général les
métiers des ressources humaines mais on
pourra également intervenir sur les
métiers de l'informatique les métiers
spécialisés en banque
alors comment ça se passe justement s'il
est des candidats peut-être enfin nous
écoutent recherchent un emploi comment
ça se passe pour vous contacter alors il
y a plusieurs possibilités soit nous
envoyer bien évidemment leur candidature
directement sur notre site via les sites
d'annoncés mais également on travaille
beaucoup par le biais de la cooptation
qui est effective dans le réseau
fonctionne très bien on va citer votre
site internet qui s'affiche d'ailleurs
en bas de votre écran de notre écran 3w
walter spipoll point fr merci c'est
fanny richard d'être venu sur notre
plateau alors c'est bientôt la fin de
cette émission mais avant on va bien sûr
regardé ensemble tous les rendez-vous
liées à l'emploi qui vous attendent et
on commence tout de suite avec
l'entreprise de services à la personne
aux deux qui organise un job dating au
pôle emploi de trappes
alors il y a deux dates jeudi 12 octobre
pour des postes d'auxiliaires de vie en
cdi et vendredi 13 octobre pour des
postes de garde d'enfants en cdi
également ses 2 9 heures à 16 heures
vendredi 13 octobre dans le cadre de la
14e édition de la semaine du handicap à
montigny le bretonneux l'hôtel de ville
accueille un andy recrutement des offres
d'emploi est destiné aux travailleurs
handicapés c'est de 9h à 12h un numéro
est à votre disposition pour plus
d'information le 0 1 39 30 30 20 et puis
à la cité des métiers attrape un atelier
sur la e-réputation ou comment utiliser
internet pour attirer les recruteurs est
organisée mercredi 18 octobre de 10h à
12h inscription obligatoire au 01 34 82
82 61
voilà c'est la fin de ce mode d'emploi
merci de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve
mardi 24 octobre pour un nouveau numéro
consacré cette fois ci aux métiers de la
science à très bientôt
[Musique]
tiens
[Rires]